Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This work is about adding color to black and
white images. There were some previous works
that tackled this problem, and many of them
worked quite well, but there were cases when
the results simply didn't make too much sense.
For instance, the algorithm often didn't guess
what color the fur of a dog should be.
If we would give the same task to a human,
we could usually expect better results because
the human knows what breed the dog is, and
what colors are appropriate for that breed.
In short, we know what is actually seen on
the image, but the algorithm doesn't - it
just trains on black and white and colored
image pairs and learns how it is usually done
without any concept of what is seen on the
image. So here is the idea - let's try to
get the neural network not only to colorize
the image, but classify what is seen on the
image before doing that. If we see a dog in
an image, it is not that likely to be pink,
is it? If we know that we have to deal with
a golf course, we immediately know to reach
out for those green crayons.
This is a novel fusion-based technique. This
means that we have a separate neural network
for classifying the images and one for colorizing
them. The fusion part is when we unify the
information in these neural networks so we
can create an output that aggregates all this
information. And the results, are just spectacular,
the additional information on what these images
are about really make a huge impact on the
quality of the results.
Please note that this is by far not the first
work on fusion, I've also linked an earlier
paper for recognizing objects in videos, but
I think this is a really creative application
of the same train of thought that is really
worthy of our attention. To delight the fellow
tinkerers out there, the source code of the
project is also available.
The supplementary video reveals that temporal
coherence is still a problem. This means that
every image is colorized separately with no
communication. It is a bit like giving the
images to colorize one by one to different
people, with no overarching artistic direction.
The result we'll get this way is a flickery
animation. This problem has been solved for
artistic style transfer, which we have discussed
in an earlier episode, the link is in the
description box.
There was one future episode planned about
plastic deformations. I have read the paper
several times, and it is excellent, but I
felt that the quality of my presentation was
not up there to put it in front of you Fellow
Scholars. It may happen in the future, but
I had to shelf this one for now. Please accept
my apologies for that. In the next episode,
we'll continue with OpenAI's great new invention
for reinforcement learning.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!